hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well at the end of his proma to any
future metaphysics ammanuel Kant has
this section solution of the general
question of the prolog Oma and the
general question is how is metaphysics
possible as science as visen shuft as a
rigorous systematic body of knowledge
that can be developed by the rational
being namely us now he's going to begin
this section by noting something quite
interesting so he says that
metaphysics as a natural disposition a
natur anaga of human reason which he's
discussed earlier in the third part of
the proma which is devoted to
metaphysics is actual it is V now this
is a German term which can be translated
as actual or real meaning that there are
things out there in history and in in
kant's own present that are calling
themselves metaphysics and he gives a
number of different examples of this in
that section so there are people doing
metaphysics thinking they're engaging in
metaphysics reading and writing books on
metaphysics having classes on it so
there's that aspect right there's
something that's called or some things
that are called
metaphysics and then he goes on and he
says but if considered by itself alone
uh fik Aline and he doesn't actually say
considered there he just says for itself
it is dialectical and illusory
so this is talking about the metaphysics
that is out there that is actual it's
not as if there's actual metaphysics and
then there's dialectical and auser
metaphysics these are two different ways
of looking at things one goes to the
library or sits in on University
lectures or in our time maybe you know
types some things into Google to do a
search term and says there's metaphysics
there the other is what Kant has
revealed to us throughout the critique
of pure reason but also this proma that
those claimants to metaphysics are in
fact dialectical and illusory and we saw
earlier that it's difficult to not do
metaphysics because we do have this
natural disposition this tendency to
want to go beyond the boundaries of mere
experience but there is some hope here
right so he says if we think of taking
principles from metaphysics and in using
them follow the natural but on that
account no less false illusion we can
never produce science but only a vain
dialectical art in which one school May
outdo one another but none can ever
acquire a just and Lasting approbation
so he goes on and he saysin order that
as a science metaphysics may be entitled
to claim Not Mere fallacious
plausibility not being on top for a
while as a philosophical school but
insight and
conviction we have to do something and
this happens through a critique of
reason if we do in fact engage in a
critique of reason and it just so
happens that at the time that he's
writing this Emanuel Kant has a whole
book called The critique of pure reason
out there and he'll follow it up with
you know critique of practical reason
and critique of judgment uh providing us
with a whole system uh over over time
then we actually can have metaphysics as
a science according to K and if we don't
do that no science right so before we
look at what this critique and science
would actually involve let's skip ahead
a little bit and look at what he calls
dogmatic metaphysics which is basically
all the metaphysics that has been done
up until that time we could add to that
skepticism which is really a rejection
of metaphysics that doesn't go far
enough and we'll see how we get to that
so he tells
us that um why do we have to do
metaphysics so reason as he says had to
have something at us beded and needed to
have something desired to have something
we could even say if we were looking at
what he said before because reason wants
us to go beyond mere experience and
perception and even you know the
scrutiny of the understanding and go
into thinking about reason and its
principles themselves we we can't avoid
for long the attraction
of engaging in metaphysics we we have to
have something so what kind of something
do we wind up with so he says that um it
couldn't find anything better for its
support and then he tells us that
critique stands in the same relation to
the common metaphysics of the schools
now you could say oh scholasticism
medieval philosophy well yes but also
cartisian philosophy also what's
happening over in Oxford in Cambridge
what's happening throughout Germany so
it's not just the metaphysics of
aristotelianism and tomis or something
like that it's also cartisian
metaphysics it's also loan metaphysics
it's also you know Li nitan and wolfian
metaphysics that is under the gun here
and he says that critique stands in the
same relation to the common metaphysics
of the schools as chemistry a real s
science that has been developed stands
in relation to Alchemy not a real
science right it's got principles you
can get books on Alchemy but it all
winds up being not nonsense but you know
illusion when we get down to it same
thing for astronomy and as the astrology
of the fortune teller
right so what do we actually have here
he Call's uh
metaphysics done by the schools an old
and sophistical sophistic right uh
pseudo science and actually the term
there there's no pseudo which means
lying in Greek right it's shine Visa
only
apparent science the illusion of science
which is what you know astrology and
alchem me according to Kant and I think
according to many people in our own time
really amount to so what we've got here
is as he's going to call it a false art
a vain wisdom italis Vice height in uh
German right and it tells us that all
false art all vain wisdom lasts its time
it endures for a while but finally
destroys
itself it it it shows itself as
incapable of satisfying the real desires
of Reason which is to have genuine
systematic reliable knowledge visen
shaft science and he says something else
that's very interesting here as
well its highest culture it was it
reaches its highest point it also Al it
attains to it's a Epoch and Epoch is
perhaps
a somewhat misleading translation it's
Epoch of Decay it's
zangas unang going under
collapsing uh Decay works for this zitp
has the sense of like coming to a point
in time it could be an era it could be
an epic so we sometimes talk about like
the modern era or you know the Roaring
20s those could be at zeit pointk but
it's a little bit less of a you know
long long stretch of time and so he says
that um that this time has come for
metaphysics appears from the state into
which it's Fallen among learned Nations
so you know those participating in the
enlightenment despite all the Zeal with
which other Sciences of every kind are
pursued the old arrangement of our
university studies still preserves its
shadow now and then an Academy of
Science tempts people by offering prizes
to write essays on it but it is no
longer numbered among sound you know
fixed established
sciences and let anyone judge for
himself how a sophisticated person if
they were called a great metaphysician
would receive the compliment which may
be well meant but is scarcely envied by
anybody so metaphysics people aren't
really that into it anymore and he talks
about this leading
into skepticism he doesn't use the term
skepticism there but we can read that
back into it and he tells us that the do
the period of the downfall of dogmatic
metaphysics has arrived but we're far
from being able to say the period of its
regeneration has come by means of a
thorough and complete critique of reason
now Kant does think that he's done a
it's just not getting the audience and
the recognition that he'd like for it so
far which is part of why he wrote the
prolog to any future metaphysics so he
says transitions from an inclination to
its contrary pass through the stage of
indifference G GTI kite right it's all
okay it's all equal equally uh not good
right and um then he says this moment is
the most dangerous for the author but
the most favorable for the Science Why
is it most favorable for metaphysics as
a science when party Spirit has died out
partisanship you know people getting
something out of being great
metaphysicians by a total dissolution of
former connections minds are in the best
state to listen to several proposals for
an organization according to a new plan
which is what Kant views himself as
having provided in his
first critique and we solidify with the
second and third critiques as well as
other things so let's talk about
critique then backing up a little bit he
tells us in part what is the critique
supposed to do what is it supposed to
provide this is in the second
paragraph a critique of Reason must
itself exhibit the whole stock of AR
priori Concepts so not some of them all
of them and you might say oh well wait a
second K you haven't actually done that
because you've done it for Pure reason
first critique but you haven't done it
for practical reason second critique
it's okay he's he's got them in his back
pocket so to speak and he'll be
exhibiting them later so exhibit the
entire stock of operary Concepts he goes
on their division according to their
various sources
sensibility understanding and reason
three different faculties that are
interconnected and work with each other
and can be arranged in a sort of
hierarchy sensibility at the bottom
understanding in between reason higher
up than them and you know really what
can govern the rest of them so that's
two things together with a complete
table of them the analysis of all these
Concepts right so that's important as
well um the uh
possibility of synthetic cognition a
priori by means of the deduction of
these Concepts the principles and Bounds
of their use and then notice the last
part all in a complete system not just a
system a complete system and here we get
to a really important feature that he is
going to stress over and over again in
this if we're going to have a genuine
critique it's got to be all the way
across the
board so he tells us a little bit later
metaphysics alone can with certainty
bring to such completion and fixity as
to require no further change or be
capable of any augmentation by new
discoveries why because reason has the
sources of its knowledge in itself not
in objects and their
observation by which its stock of
knowledge could be further increased and
here we see the difference for example
as he's mentioned earlier between bounds
or
boundaries right and then mere limits so
mathematics we can keep on finding new
discoveries about how numbers quantity
Works its application of space and stuff
like that we can kind of never finish
with it
metaphysics we can actually according to
Kant finish with it at least in the
general or the
abstract and so he tells us that uh when
it is exhibited the fundamental laws of
its faculty completely and so
determinately as to avoid all
misunderstanding there's nothing more
for Pure reason to cognize a priority
there's even no ground to raise any
further
questions Kant takes himself at least
with respect to Pure reason in the first
critique to have done exactly that now
has he done that completely in the pra
no because it is uh a pra it's a much
shorter work it's presenting things in a
different manner right but he says that
he's thinking these proma will excite
investigation in the field of critique
and afford a new and promising object
right and so he says I can imagine
beforehand everyone whom the thorny
Paths of my critique have tired and put
out of humor will ask me on what I found
this hope my answer the irresistible law
of necessity now what is this law you
can't avoid doing metaphysics you're
inevitably led by this natural
disposition into taking positions in
metaphysics metaphysics is actual but
you want it to be a science not a pseudo
science right not dogmatic metaphysics
and you don't want to fall into
skepticism so he says there will always
be metaphysics in the World everyone
especially every reflective man will
have it and for want of a recognized
standard will shape it for himself after
his own pattern what has been called
metaphysics up till now cannot satisfy
any critical mind but to forgo it is
entirely impossible so a critique of
pure reason itself must now be attempted
or now notice this very convenient
phrase or if one exists investigated and
brought to the full full test because
there's no other means for supplying
this pressing want right so just so
happens that as I mentioned before Kant
does have a critique worked out that you
can easily get your hands on purchase
read for yourself I mean it's a little
bit self-serving but you know it's not
self-serving in a in a bad way here con
saying look I've got a critique
available for you you just got to
actually read it study it attentively
and that's very important as we see in
the next section where he engages one of
his critics who is not looking at it
quite so attentively there's one last
thing that we want to touch on here
which is uh this discussion of um
analytic treatment of things and he says
that the science of metaphysics is not
Advanced because of analyses of
Concepts um you can analyze the concept
of substance and accident uh you can
analyze you know other things like uh
propositions like the the uh uh you know
sufficient reason or anything like that
but in analyzing you're not actually
advancing things what we need are
synthetic a
priori Concepts propositions uh
judgments uh cognitions to go back to
the terminology that he's been using
this entire work and that is indeed what
the critique of pure reason is supposed
to be providing us either with
or uh with the possibility the
guidelines for deriving our self so this
is how Kant conceives of his project in
the first critique and what he has to
tell us about it in relation to the
metaphysics that's out there but really
doesn't deserve the name at this point
because it's
at best pseudo science that needs to be
replaced by a real metaphysics that
can't thinks that he's paved the way
towards